ein anderes team das genau so mancher
nicht einfach jemanden gehört ja wohin
herzlich willkommen zu war u3 warum ich
dabei wird später irgendwann erklärt ich
bin die metallischen fünfte kolossal
oder erstmal weiß noch sonntag nicht so
ist geht in zehn sekunden los wir haben
die krasseste tag gerade wir sind so gut
vorbereitet das ist unfassbar in der tat
gehen ab brauchst du auch schon ab
gerade ja ich hab zwei blöcke ich glaube
nicht runter geht schon liegt schon was
nicht schon mal und ich haben blogger
bei mir jetzt steine neben ihr stein
nehmen wir auch ist nicht irgendein ich
brauche ich aber trotzdem schon mal
weiter rund ich habe mich auch weiter
runter ich bin am sinken
aber ich kann
du kannst ja nicht weiter runter als
wasserkirche okay also wir haben wir
gleich in die villen fall drin
nomination hat auf jeden fall schon mal
den server verlassen
oh mein gott alter freunde also wir
haben wirklich hell oder so ich werde
gleich nochmal darüber in ruhe reden
wieso ich noch dabei bin und 2010 fort
wollen wir mal ganz groß unsere taktik
gewählt erklären erklärte mal ich also
ich gehe jetzt nicht weiter herunter
erstmal weil ich nicht gar nicht sehe
gerade
ich habe auch ehrlich gesagt angst ist
unter uns ein bisschen lava ist ich hab'
ich bleibe ist ein verstehen ich mache
jetzt ganz okay ich lebe
vielleicht kommt ja treffen man darf er
erst mal zeigen
da wurde getötet der dreck
was wird es dann richtig viel gestorben
nicht - auch schon tot glaube ich und
meine frau ist auch jeder autor also
hatte ich den hier wollte ich auch noch
halten um so taktik ok freunde unsere
taktik beginnt genau jetzt
[Musik]
oder nicht
die jungs
jetzt war der alltag die lka sachsen max
ist schon wieder gestorben ist nicht
links
das ist aus dem bergwerk eine also
freunde das gerade taktik jetzt
wahrscheinlich an die hinterlegte kommen
ja ich weiss nicht also mal ganz klar
verloren tatsächlich okay ich gar nix ja
damit das zufall sein weil dir irgendwie
dass du vielleicht kurz gesprungen bist
oder was weiß ich also mal ganz kurz
sicher klar dass mal eben kurz was
unsere eigentliche taktik war ist jedoch
tot
ja ich wollte es mit kers ins team
zurück wenn ich jetzt noch mit dir also
hatte ich war eigentlich dass wir uns
direkt am anfang runter buddeln weil wir
beide nicht so die besten pvp spieler
sind bereit deswegen dachten wir haben
uns direkt runter damit wir dann quasi
alltag wie viele tötet wenigen ein wenig
hat schon drei leute gekillt alter was
ist das denn für ein kranker scheiß und
wir stehen hier unseren scheiß [ __ ]
loch einfach richtige müssten wir sind
ja so behindert naja die triba und
direkt runter und stehen irgendwo es kay
wurde getötet alter was ist los wir
leben nur die ghanaer gewinnen wir das
ding weil sie sich gegen nicht töten
wir müssen uns die ganze zeit irgendwo
verstecken
also ist das grobe grobe ding war becken
uns unter unserer dings unter unserem
startpunkt sage ich mal
und dann kriegt uns quasi keiner sage
ich mal da war allerdings direkt
steinbock und deswegen hat uns dann eben
runter graben und den rest hat gesehen
wir haben wirklich keine richtige tanken
das war unsere taktik
oh gott wir haben sogar schon gesagt
dass wir jetzt so wurde wenig spielen
oder so einen scheiß sie hatten also die
erste folge wird wirklich nur unten sein
das heißt wir werden abwarten und
versuchen die erste folge zu erleben und
die zweite und dritte da werden wir dann
auch alle töten sowie weniger artisten
haben wieso erst mal erklären warum du
überhaupt dabei ist die lustig ist ja
sowieso wir beide
ich hatte ja ewig keinen partner ich
hatte ja nie irgendwie der partner und
gowalla und wir kriegen davon einfach
nichts mehr war als am land
ach so ja ich hatte ja gesagt dass ich
nicht dabei bin also wartet das nicht
auch noch die ganze zeit aufgestellt
ich drücke so fest auf ich drücke aus
ich habe schon mal den finger
also ich hatte ja am anfang gesagt so ja
warum bin ich nicht dabei als der termin
bekanntgegeben wurde und so weiter und
so fort
weil ich da eigentlich nach kanada beute
allerdings hat sich dann zwei wochen
später ergeben dass das mit kanada doch
nicht irgendwie so stattfinden kann bzw
doch nicht dann ist anders ist und so
weiter und so fort das sind total
komische sachen aber jetzt noch nicht
alles zu sagen jetzt ist auf jeden fall
dann dort hat dann doch geklappt und ich
konnte dann noch einmal rein und ich
wollte erst irgendwie team mit boss
machen oder so dann wollte ich team mit
sk machen und dann habe ich gedacht
verdammt diese alle schon weg die haben
alle schon partner die einzigen die noch
frei waren waren halt so leute die ich
quasi für den ich noch nie geredet hatte
und ich kann mich mit leuten lagern so
quasi mit ihm geredet hat und mit felix
hallodri habe ich schon damals sehr viel
fitter gespielt und 2
jedenfalls habe ich dann gesagt ja auch
kaum belasten team machen
felix und ich sind beide sehr schlecht
aber wir leben doch wir sind und jahren
top und was weiß ich
radio- und kilos die sind beide schon
tot mit denen du team wollte
ja deswegen das ist halt schon krass es
ist sehr gut gelaufen bis jetzt also ich
bin auch sehr zufrieden mit der taktik
ich lebe länger als letztes mal das war
mein ziel nehmen auch vorhin gesagt so
was schön wäre luca dummer ist ja
irgendwie fünf folgen wären schön ich
war schon mit drei folgen zufrieden
irgendwann hatte ich einfach so weiter
runter geschraubt dass ich gesagt habe
einfach die erste folge überleben das
wäre ja warum eigentlich ganz gut auch
ja es sieht echt aus und weiß was ich
mache ich bei mir unten quasi so ein
kleiner raum h
und zwar wirklich immer noch im krieg
und baut die ganze zeit steiner habe ich
verliere keinen einzigen hunger waren
wohl die ganze liga dass heißt dies ab
und verliert man mal nicht meine ich nix
du hast wahrscheinlich auch noch 100
balken also ein hungerlohn halbe was
unseren halben jahr dann wird das
irgendwie vom fallen gewesen seien keine
ahnung wir spielen auch
schwierigkeitsgrade hart das gibt sonst
noch für infos
das heißt wenn ihr das video gerade
sieht ist der achtzehnte siebte
wahrscheinlich irgendwann mittags um 12
uhr geht das online und die nächste
folge wird dann morgen kommen
vorausgesetzt überleben das ganze jetzt
noch das stimmt aber wo ist er jetzt
nicht was passieren sollte was
eigentlich nicht passieren einer keiner
läuft zum sport und gibt alles um keiner
hat diese taktik je in faro gemacht das
ist eine revolutionäre taktik quasi oder
ist revolutionär reisen sie das gesehen
haben das ist so wie kann das sein
das ist doch ein versuch das aller
lustigste wer was wenn einfach ein
anderes team das genau so mancher ich
habe gehört dass sogar abgebaut schreibt
gerade einsteigen
[Musik]
also ein kabel gesetzt hat block achtet
erdloch hast du gesagt okay ich glaube
die sich jetzt über links gehört ich
werde versuchen für die am besten nichts
setzen am besten nur abbauen und auch
wenn stein abbauen
ich versuche ich mal zu dir über zu
graben da wo ich das gehört habe aber
ich will ja nicht ich habe ja quasi
alles zuge wurde weil wenn jetzt sofort
jemand oben den ersten block abbaut und
direkt im loch reinschaut und weiß ja
dass da jemand ist aber das wird keine
abbauen
definitiv nein der hund auffällig war
ich hab alles was ich abgebaut habe und
ich bin runter gefallen aber ich alles
wieder schön überhaupt ich habe auch
gerade was gehörten setzen willst du
dass ich habe das von rechts gehört
hatte jetzt im block abgebaut ja ich
versuche mal rüber zu kommen also dann
sind wir wenigstens bei ihnen genau die
gleiche taktik setzen so genau
gleichzeitig auch so block dort treffen
wir auf einmal auf andere irgendwie of
five oder so wir haben uns ja aber
weiter heute gilt ja wenn da müssen die
das links und halte ich habe angst ich
mach mir ein dickes ding hier also
freundlich kann es natürlich vollkommen
verstehen wenn jetzt sagt molz
langweilig oder gesagt es ist halt die
erste folge und unser ziel war wirklich
einfach wirklich zu überleben das heißt
es müsste jetzt respektieren die zweite
und dritte folge mit dann natürlich da
gehen wir dann raus und so weiter und so
fort
das heißt wenn jetzt nicht sehen wollte
ja genau werden ja genau
also ich nehme jetzt auch schon seit
neun minuten auf den fünf minuten sechs
minuten ist sehr wichtig
yahoo hatte ich dann angst hier noch
gegen jakub war nicht einmal nur so
genau wo ich sein versuch das loch ist
ja ich glaube jetzt die ganze zeit
abbauen
ich habe gar nichts gemacht ich bin
einfach nur gestanden ja ich weiß aber
auch nichts mehr ich habe es echt angst
dass noch irgendwann die mitte kommt
irgendwie was macht also braucht den
alltag
wir werden wahrscheinlich die erste map
pack in folge erleben wie froh sie nicht
oder falsch
ich bin sofort auf diesen künftig auch
werde ich den rest habe ich direkt angst
ist irgendwie da ist völlig marode
machen will für germania wer dort lebt
kann ich kann nichts nikon f 3 drücken
ich weiß ich habe vorhin jetzt mit mit
dem inventar ausprobiert da ging es
nicht
ich will es nicht riskieren nicht in der
zweiten folge ist mir alles egal
hauptsache ich überlebe die sich ja wohl
jeder schreit aber schon wieder
wir wollen es joachim frey als auch aus
das heißt wenn ich die box geht auch
nicht das war testen es gibt natürlich
auch wieder so ein regelwerk wo alles
mögliche drinsteht von wegen welche
items von benutzen darf brauche ich euch
allerdings gar nicht sagen weil ich das
erstens gar nicht weiß und wir beide von
uns beschlossen haben dass wir so weit
nicht kommen werden
wir sind auf jeden fall optimistisch
dass merck schon lustig ja es ist ein
weit kommen würden ich denke wir würden
aber wenn schon so weit kommen dass wir
dementsprechend dann irgendwann uns
außerdem mache und dann kriegen wir
strike und dann sind unsere laden
irgendwie dann passiert ja irgendwas bei
streiks hier das sagen da fasst dann
passiert das öffentlich habe ich habe
keine ahnung also hier sehen wir sind
bestens informiert informierten aber wir
leben noch und ich hatte vorher noch mit
sk geschrieben und sk meide so viel
glück wie krank und ich weiß genau wie
die leute sich fühlen ja ich weiß nicht
genau wie man irgendwo
es läuft halt wirklich besonders
selbsthilfegruppe dann ab materie und
antonio ich bin todtraurig auch als
video gestorben zeig mal deine aufnahme
dann schreibt ersten das schon laden das
direkt hoch da kann sie den tod von den
anderen trick anschauen ja das war
letztes mal echt zu fassade haben das
direkt oft nicht gelistet hochgeladen
und ein linker herumgeführt
damit jeder direkt wegen konnte was ich
gestorben bin wie unnötig na ja es gab
aber echt so genannte methode mit lover
so letzten mal steht auf jeden fall
jetzt irgendwie hat richtig harte
probleme kann das sein
die arme
jetzt ja auch nicht anders
ich sage schon letztes jahr im januar
oder so eine händlerin
neben der ausgesprochen gamer stylist
noch mit denen noch zusammen
ja der ist aber schon gestorben was ja
den da ist gestorben stand da ganz am
anfang immer ist der tv ist gestorben
deswegen runtergefallen wahrscheinlich
aber timo ist mit max wenn ja wie viele
sind denn tot wie viele verschrecken
denn wir leben wir einfach noch wie
krank ist das metall audrey hier ist
einfach die richtige feiglinge aber es
ist wurscht ich sage die wir gewinnen
das ding jetzt alter wie cool ist das
denn die aufnahme ist gerade bei mir bei
zwölf minuten das heißt noch drei
minuten oder so müsst ihr unser gelaber
hier noch ausstehen und ich muss mich
echt mein land so klein
ich muss mich erst mal dafür
entschuldigen dass wir dieses video
jetzt so dumm verbringen weil das ist ja
es ist noch schlimmer als es folge wo
der in der wand stand weil ihr sie hat
ja wenigstens noch ein bisschen
anspannung sonne da weiter sogar ganz
ausgerottet ist ausgestorben von gamers
teil der macht alleine jetzt gern was
kann die ship diamanten nicht diamanten
diamanten
er hat noch 560 sekunden aufnahme
deshalb kommt tobi ist doch so die 15
minuten laufen seitdem er geträumt jetzt
na ja das heißt wenn jetzt rein
theoretisch zwischendurch wieder weg
joint dann kriegt er die zeitung noch
drauf dazwischen oder naja die die läuft
ja dann nicht weiter deswegen hat er für
eine viertelstunde pro tag so weit ist
dann hat er aber dadurch dass er so oft
vom server genommen soccer nachher eine
halbe minute meer oder in die oder
ich weiß nicht wie das mit der
schutzzeit ist und die schutzzeit halt
diese 10 sekunden oder was das sind
neapel hatte stand mit zählen also ich
mein halt er ist ja schon mal vor ich
habe noch zehn minuten nicht aufnehmen
kann und dann werde ich vom server
geschickt wegen internet problem und
dann brauche ich eine halbe minute um
das wieder hinzubiegen habe ich dann
noch zehn minuten aufnahmezeit oder neun
minuten 30 quasi letzten zehn minuten
okay weil dann hätte ja rein theoretisch
tobi konnte er um rein theoretische
klänge auf dem server bleiben also ist
ja auch komplett egal der doch keinen
vorteil dann großartig tobias ist er
gestorben und daher aber die nazis und
wieder allein aber genauso war es
letztes jahr auch oder dabei auch
einfach fast jeder tod ich fühle mich
jetzt noch einfach so krasser ich noch
lebe ich lebe noch und wir weiter als
absolute bvb kasten bastarde und fußball
und genau das zeigen wir aber auch dass
wir nichts können ja das ist einfach so
hasst uns einfach und schreibe es in die
kommentare
so aber dann machen wir nicht das wasser
reichen
sr stark de nichts kommt da müsste ja
das tun was ihr nicht könnt zwar nichts
tun
es macht keinen sinn denn überhaupt kein
wunder geben wenn ihr nix könnt dann
macht ihr das was sie nicht könnt nichts
nämlich nicht ach so ja es stimmt das
macht doch sinn
stimmt sich das kann echt nichts bei mir
bei 15 minuten das heißt eine halbe
minute sollte mir geklickt werden kommen
dann wieder so nachrichten im chat soja
ihr werdet denn daran getan und dann
gekriegt als ich kenne das nicht ich war
noch nie dabei so lange gar nicht aus
alter ich weiß doch überhaupt nicht
alter ich lebe ein ordner
ich lebe noch wie krank ist dass sie ihr
leben noch hallo ihr leben noch dass ich
immer an meine sonnenbrille ausziehen
kann aber kurz 20 sekunden zu einem lied
wackeln was wir jetzt hinter gesamt
umklappen müssen wir auf dem
kindergeburtstag wenn diese dinge darauf
müssen wir aber nie freunde die nächste
folge wird wirklich so wir gehen dann
hier raus wir holen uns holzmachen und
altem scrum und sagen wahrscheinlich
denke ich sogar wieder ein am ende der
folge irgendwo und wir versuchen
wirklich die apps apps tod alter 1
sekunde vorn geschickt wurde
aber es ist echt krass richtig
verstanden aus freunde an dieser stelle
wir würden uns über jede bewertung
freuen irgendwie sorry nochmal dass wir
jetzt die ganzen und sie haben die
letzte folge überlebt wir haben die
erste mal geladener ist alles
aufgebraucht
loslassen hastig ob die pfäffiker so so
geil hifi und klatscht in die hände
ok freunde ja wir haben die erste folge
überlebt die nächste folge kommt morgen
auf meine mutter ist kanal hallodri
unternimmt in der beschreibung verlinkt
so dass wir die ganze zeit unten waren
nächste folge wird das ganze besser ja
wir haben so erlebt wie krass also ja
was hast du da irgendwie uns unser team
dame herrscht erste folge tod sollte was
cool auf jeden fall sehr amüsant mega
lust ist waschtag oder die taktik gut
was los